[Music]  an update out of afghanistan the first  international passenger flight carrying  americans and other foreigners have left  kabul today the flight marked progress  in talks between the u.s and  afghanistan's new taliban leaders it's  believed there are about a hundred  americans still in the country but it's  unclear how many afghan allies will be  able to get out but it's a start  certainly today's departure of this  qatar airways charter was a welcome step  it is certainly something  that we were glad to see happen  cbs news confirms another qatar air  charter flight out of kabul may be in  the works for friday